-After slogging through
months of painful
negotiations over
their domestic agenda,
Democratic leaders
and President Biden
claimed today that
they´ve reached a deal
on a framework
for a massive bill
to expand the social safety net,
but it´s still not clear
if there are enough votes
for the plan.
For more on this,
it´s time for "A Closer Look."
♫♫
To give you an idea of
how things are going
in Congress right now,
here´s a photo
Utah Senator Mitt Romney
posted today of himself
dressed up as Ted Lasso,
serving biscuits to
Democratic Senator
Kyrsten Sinema.
Man, you know you´re unpopular
when you can
single-handedly ruin one of
America´s favorite TV shows.
This is like when Rudy Giuliani
ran out of
the White House bathroom
with his pants
around his ankles,
George Costanza-style.
Or like when Nixon showed up
to a press conference
dressed as Radar O´Reilly.
The "M.A.S.H."
references are back!
But this just proves once again
that we desperately need
Roy Kent in Congress,
because that picture
makes me want to...
-[Bleep]
-Now,
even if you only been
paying cursory attention
to the news lately,
you´ve probably heard
that Democratic negotiations
over their
massive infrastructure
and social safety net bills
have been --
and this is the exact
political science term,
originally coined by historian
Doris Kearns Goodwin
in her prize-winning study
of power and influence
in the 19th century --
a [bleep]-covered,
ass-over-teakettle
cluster[bleep].
That´s from the X-rated version
of her famous book,
"Team of Mother[bleep] Rivals."
By the way, that is
the most high-minded joke
you´ll hear tonight that also
has three bleeps in it.
The process has been
a brutal slog,
thanks almost entirely
to two centrist Democrats,
Joe Manchin
and Kyrsten Sinema,
who decided to
hold the bill hostage
and turn it into
a public melodrama
to feed their own egos and to
protect their corporate patrons.
Sinema´s raked in money from
Wall Street and Big Pharma,
and Manchin has been
called a kingmaker
by fossil fuel lobbyists
and personally profits from
the coal industry in his state.
And yet Manchin frequently
does a "woe is me" routine
for reporters,
like earlier this week
when he seemed to agree
that life might be easier
for him if he were a Republican.
-Have you ever thought life
would be easier for you
if you shifted
to being a Republican?
And somebody had said recently
that, you know,
people have approached
you about doing that.
-Every day.
-Every day?
-Well, either that or just --
-It might be easier
for you to do that?
-Oh, I´d be much easier.
My goodness´ sake.
But is that the purpose of being
involved in public service?
Because it´s easy?
-Are you thinking
about doing it?
-No, I´ve never. I´ve
never thought from this....
What I´m telling you now
is who I am.
Do you think by having
a D or an I or an R,
it´s going to change who I am?
I don´t think the R´s would
be any more happier with me
than the D´s are right now.
Okay?
I mean, that´s about
as blunt as I can put it,
so I don´t know
where in the hell I belong.
-Man, this adaptation
of "Dear Evan Hansen" sucks.
They should never have
left someone that old
play a high schooler.
But seriously,
is this a musical?
Are you about
to break out into song?
He looks like you should be
sitting next to a fake window,
looking at a cardboard
cut-out of the moon.
♫ I have D next to my name ♫
♫ But I´m not sure that
I´m the same ♫
♫ Where do I belong? ♫
[ Scattered applause ]
I think there was seriously
one, solitary clap,
but it was like
a reverse clap.
It was this.
This is all just
a self-aggrandizing shtick
from two senators
who want to be seen
as straight-,hooting
middle-of-the-road dealmakers,
but who are in reality
just protecting their interests
of the corporate patrons
and themselves.
I mean,
Manchin literally has a stake
in a family-owned coal company
in his so-called houseboat
named Almost Heaven,
where he was confronted
recently by activists
who literally kayaked there
to ask him questions.
-I´m sorry,
but that´s not a houseboat.
That´s a yacht.
You know how I know?
Houseboats don´t have
cursive on them.
A houseboat´s something
a grizzled, retired cop
played by Clint Eastwood
or Tommy Lee Jones
lives on in a movie
where a young rookie
comes to him asking for help
catching the Alphabet Killer.
"I told you, I´m not
on the force anymore."
"But you´re the only one who´s
come close to catching him."
"Didn´t you hear me, damn it?
I´m not a cop anymore.
Hell, I´m not even a man
after Janice left me.
I don´t know
where the hell I belong."
♫ Oh, where do I belong? ♫
[ Applause ]
Manchin has been the key foe of
budget chairman Bernie Sanders,
who´s been pushing
for the full package
that originally included,
among other things,
drug pricing reform,
tuition-free community college,
paid family and medical leave,
Medicare benefits for
hearing, vision, and dental,
and significant
climate provisions
to help stave off,
you know, planetary collapse.
Although, I guess
you´re not too worried
about rising sea levels
when your house is also a boat.
Publicly,
in front of the cameras,
Manchin has very much tried
to make it look like
he´s negotiating
in good faith with Bernie,
like when he wandered over
to pose for pictures with Bernie
in the Capitol parking lot
before
they each got into their cars.
-Here, get a picture.
You want to get a picture?
-Get a picture of us, huh?
-We´re talking.
-You´re going to have
a resolution
by the end of the week
at some point?
-We´re talking.
We´re going
to make some progress.
-Senator Sanders, are you
prepared to make some deep cuts
to climate change
and other things like that?
-Guys, watch the vehicles,
please.
Come on out.
That vehicle´s going
to come out.
-My favorite part of
that clip is at the end,
when Manchin slides
comfortably into a giant pickup
and Bernie squeezes into
what I can only assume
is the smallest
compact car on the market
that came pre-installed
with three carpoolers.
-[ As Bernie Sanders ]
"No radio, no chitchat,
just off to work
and home again."
And it is very on-brand
that Bernie
is much less enthusiastic
than Manchin
for a bull[bleep] photo op.
Manchin´s got the energy
of a used car salesman
shooting his own commercial,
and Bernie is having none of it.
"Yep, sure. We´re talking.
And as you know, famously,
talking is
my favorite thing to do.
I just love to sit around
and waste time
making small talk with guys
who live on houseboats.
Why don´t we exchange
phone numbers
so you can call me
and we can stay up
until 3:00 AM,
talking about
our hopes and dreams,
what we´re going
to wear to prom?
And then maybe after
that we can find some time
to make some matching
friendship places."
But in private, Manchin has
been much more hostile
to Bernie´s agenda --
an agenda President Biden
himself, mind you,
has said he was fully behind.
"Axios" reported last week
that Manchin threatened
in a meeting with Bernie
and other Democrats
to kill both the bigger
social safety net bill
and a bipartisan
infrastructure bill.
Manchin and Sanders
squabbled behind closed doors,
with Manchin using
a raised-fist "goose egg"
to tell his colleague
he can live without
any of the president´s
social spending plan.
According to one senator
in the room,
Joe said, "I´m comfortable
with nothing."
Bernie said, "We need
to do $3.5 trillion."
Manchin said,
"I´m comfortable with zero,"
forming a zero with
his thumb and index finger.
Alright, first of all,
never get into
a hand gesture battle
with Bernie Sanders.
The man uses his index fingers
the way ninjas use
throwing stars.
Remember the debate?
He never had to say a word.
He´d just raise
that index finger
while someone else was talking,
and it would be like
watching The Rock
pick up his microphone.
But say all you want
about Manchin --
and clearly, we´ve said a lot.
At least he´s a Democrat
from West Virginia,
where Trump won
by almost 40 points.
Sinema, on the other hand,
is from Arizona --
a state Joe Biden won --
where her poll numbers
among Democrats
have collapsed
thanks to her obstructionism.
And unlike Manchin, she never
even talks to the press --
or to voters, for that matter.
She holds private fundraisers
and meetings with lobbyists.
But then, when constituents
and reporters try
to get answers out of her,
this happens.
[ Radio chatter ]
Man, reporters
are getting desperate.
They´re starting to sound
like a family
trapped in an escape room.
Puzzle-master!
Can you give us a clue?
Anything?!
We´ve been here for three days!
Sinema blocked everything
from increased taxes
on the wealthy
to drug pricing reform --
some of the most popular
components of the bill.
And in the process,
she and Manchin have turned
an entire negotiation
into a nightmare slog
to the point where even
reporters and correspondents
are having trouble keeping up
with what´s in the bill
and what´s not.
Likely in -- universal pre-K,
a one-year extension
of the Child Tax Credit,
childcare center funding,
Pell Grant increases,
some unspecified
climate change funding,
and an elder care provision.
Now, here´s what might be out.
Free community college.
This was very important
to progressives.
Expanded Medicare coverage.
That includes dental, vision,
and hearing coverage.
The Clean Electricity
Performance Program.
That is a major
climate initiative.
And tax hikes on corporations
and high earners.
What´s still under discussion?
Well, an $800 Medicare
dental voucher program,
four weeks of federal
paid family leave,
expansions in red states
that haven´t
expanded it already,
and, to pay for it --
you´ve heard a lot about this --
a billionaire wealth tax.
So, it´s a lot to cover.
Out -- mom jeans.
In -- hip-huggers.
Out -- the Kardashians.
In -- the Jenners.
This process has been so chaotic
they had to break out
the big board.
Next thing you know,
they´re gonna run
Steve Kornacki out there
to do math on the fly
while they feed him
a steady diet
of paper and Sharpie.
Now, the list of what´s in
includes a lot
of great transformative stuff
like the child tax credit,
universal pre-K,
and some major climate stuff,
among other things, but the list
of what´s out is infuriating.
For one thing, how can anyone be
against drug pricing reform
or free community college
or paid family leave?
We´re one of only
a small handful of countries
that doesn´t have it --
it´s insane.
Everyone deserves the right
to be at home
with their families
and children.
And besides --
in my experience,
the more time you spend
with your kids,
the more desperate you are
to go back to work.
After a week of lockdown
with my family,
I called up NBC and said,
"We need to do the show
in the attic!"
By the way, I still
can´t believe we lost
the Best Show In An Attic Emmy
to BBC´s period drama,
"Upstairs: Even More Upstairs."
And that´s a perfect example
of the kind of high-effort,
low-return joke
we learned to tell...
when doing a show in an attic.
That joke would have killed
in the attic.
The audience
would have been buzzing
because the audience were wasps.
[ Laughter ]
But after all the obstructionism
and hostage-taking
and painful cuts today,
Democrats claim they had
a tentative deal
on a framework for a bill,
and Biden himself
went to the Hill to tout it,
claiming everyone was on board.
-Is Bernie Sanders
on board, sir?
-It´s not a good sign
when Biden´s talking
like an Amtrak conductor
who dozed off.
"Hey, man, shouldn´t you be
saying ´all aboard´?"
"Why? I´m on board.
You´re on board.
We´re all on board, right?"
So, there you go --
the process was painful,
the cuts were brutal,
but at least now, finally,
Democrats have a deal
everyone can get behind, right?
-And We heard from
Senator Dick Durbin
a short time ago
after the meeting started.
He said, "I wish
I could say yes,
but there´s a great deal of
uncertainty within the caucus."
He was asked
if he´s confident
all 50 Democrats in the Senate
are on board.
He couldn´t say yes.
-What? Then, what the hell was
this announcement all about?
Don´t tout the deal
unless the deal is done.
Don´t be the dad that says,
"Who wants to go to Disneyland?"
And then, after
the kids scream "yes"
go online to see
if tickets are available.
Okay. Just remember, kids --
we have very inflexible dates,
so fingers crossed."
Ohhhh, shoot, shoot, shoot,
shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Who wants to go
to Busch Gardens?
Stop hitting me!
I am your father!
Don´t you throw
that "Lego brick" at me.
[ Laughter ]
The stakes for this bill
cannot be overstated.
Democrats have to deliver
on their promises,
boost the economy,
and give voters a reason
to keep them in office.
Otherwise, the people
who could very well take power
in 2022 and 2024
are the GOP cult
of authoritarian weirdos,
leaving the rest of us to say,
"I don´t know
where in the hell I belong."
This has been "A Closer Look."
♫♫
God´s Love, We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you´re watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe.
Get vaccinated.
We love you.